foreign
[Music]
my name is Amir Mitchell and today I'd
like to talk with you about our work on
bacterial adaptation to host targeting
chemotherapies and how that adaptation
Alters drug metabolism
before I do that I just want to say a
few words about the microbiome the human
microbiome
the human microbiome is a collective
term we use to describe diverse
organisms bacteria archaea fungi and
protists and viruses that pretty much
cover every nuke and surface on our body
we tend to think of ourselves as super
organisms because of the microbiome
that actually contains about two to
three times more cells than the cells in
the human body
the microbiome brings to the table a
huge pan genome
lots of genes that complement our own
genome and are essential for our health
and development
in the recent decade or so there has
been huge interest in the microbiome and
how the microbiome actually impacts our
proper development in our health
recent work also looks at how the
microbiome interacts with cancer disease
a disease progression and treatment
success
invisible cases we know of bacteria or
microbiome involvement in causing
cancers but I would say that these are
the rare cases
if it's much more common from what we
know now is for the microbiome to
actually influence cancer disease
progression for multiple mechanisms some
of them could be interaction with the
cancer cells or the immune response of
the human host
or another very frequent form of
interaction is influence on treatment
success by bacterial metabolism of drugs
that are targeted at the tumor so
bacterial metabolism can have a huge
impact by different forms of drug
metabolism are either activating drugs
processing drugs or degrading drugs on
the treatment success
recent work has shown that we need to
think of the microbiome not only in
natural microbiome sites like the gut or
the skin but actually also
holding the microbiome within tumors
we now know that a lot of tumors in
different sites could become
persistently infected with bacteria
and we termed these bacteria that
colonize tumors the tumor microbiome
in some cases it's very natural to call
contaminated tumors especially in sites
that are naturally exposed to a
microbiome like the gut
colon cancers mouth cancer skin cancers
but we now know that cancers even at
very sterile sites like brain cancers
bone cancers pancreatic cancers can
become infected with a persistent tumor
microbial
so all the interactions I was referring
to earlier
immunomodulation
drug processing and degradation can
actually transpire not only in natural
sites but also in the intimate settings
of the tumor micro environment
and these interactions can be very very
potent in that very specific niche
so again all these interactions also
happen within the context of the tumor
microbi
another thing that is worth pointing out
when we think about the tumor microbiome
is recent recent attempts to use
bacteria
to intentionally infect tumors and
colonize tumors as part of a therapeutic
approach there are now clinical trials
trying to actually infect tumor
specifically with probiotic strains or
engineered strains that are supposed to
either secret toxins or process drugs as
a theropoic application
but again that's a synthetic tumor
microbiome but it's all also worth being
aware of that context
generally speaking I think the field
sees the microbiome as a modulator of
the drug tumor interactions and the
microbiome either in natural sites or in
the tumor can
implicate for their diverse direct and
indirect mechanisms the strength of that
interaction between the tumors and the
drugs
but I would argue here that this
tumor-centric approach misses on
something fundamental about
chemotherapies and that is that many
host targeted drugs and definitely many
chemotherapies are highly toxic not just
for the human host and for the tumor
cells that are actually also very toxic
to the microbiome
we now think that about 50 of our
chemotherapies are highly cytotoxic
agents also for bacteria
so if we think about the same
interaction from the perspective of the
microbiome the microbiome might need to
actually adapt and respond to these
chemotherapies with prolonged treatment
the questions I want to put forth here
is can bacteria either within the
natural sites of the microbiome or
within the tuber microbiome can evolve
to become chemotherapy resistant
and if they do will bacterial adaptation
actually influence the host treatment
itself
we know currently nothing about these
processes although they are very likely
to happen
to study this hypothesis we use the
model system
a very simplified model systems in which
we used CL against the worm as our host
to fairly understood chemotherapies five
a few and fudr and in our case my the
microbiome was actually the E coli diet
that the worms feed on and actually
colonizes the worm gut so this is our
model system to try to understand
bacterial adaptation and its whole
simplification in the context of the
worm host
before I go into the research itself
I'll just briefly explain the drug
mechanism or the toxicity mechanism of
these chemotherapies we have a fairly
good understanding of the toxicity
mechanism of these chemotherapies in
bacteria and in whole cells in human
cells and mammalian cells and it's a
very similar mechanism
so bacteria like many other cells
can either uptake nucleotides and
nucleosides from their environment using
the Salvage pathway as you can see here
in this example it's your cell and
uradin
or they can make their own nucleotides
using the de novo nucleotide synthesis
pathway and of course nucleotides are
essential building components for the
cells that are needed for RNA and DNA
metabolism
the two drugs I was mentioning 50 and
fudr actually exploit the Salvage
pathway
they are transported into the cells
using very similar mechanisms for
nucleotide transport
they get phosphorylated and they
interfere through various mechanisms
with RNA and DNA synthesis
previous Works have shown that
as in the context of sorry a worm host
bacteria actually accumulate a toxic
intermediate of these Pro drugs and that
toxic intermediate shown here in my
diagram is highly toxic for the worm
host
not only that previous Works have also
demonstrated that mutations in denoted
synthesis pathway either in the Salvage
pathway or in the neurosynthesis pathway
in bacteria can Impact Drug toxicity in
the host
so again this is just the mechanism of
these two chemotherapies in bacteria and
in the worm host
the first question we wanted to ask are
are these chemotherapies even really
toxic for bacteria
in order to do that we use standard
sensitivity curves we measured bacterial
optical density after 12 hours of growth
in the presence of this these two drugs
and we repeated our experiments both in
nutrient rich in a nutrient poor medium
in both cases in both drugs we saw that
these drugs are indeed highly cytotoxic
for bacteria
but one interesting observation was that
the toxicity is actually much much
higher in nutrient poor media
in retrospect it makes a lot of sense
the reason the probable reason for the
high toxicity nutrient poor media is
that nutrient poor media does not have
any nucleotides on closets in the
extracellular environment and these
potential and metabolites can compete
with these drugs for intracellular
transport so in poor nature and media
there's no competition only the drugs
are transported into the cells and
that's why we see the higher toxicity
again both for five of you and for fudr
how do these toxicity profiles compare
with what we see in cancer cells well
actually if you compare it to previous
Works looking at the panel of a few
hundred cancer cell lines and you look
at the median toxicity for these
Airlines you can see that the toxicity
we see in the bacteria are comparable if
not even higher than what we observe for
cancer cells
so we can definitely check that
interaction these two chemotherapies are
highly cytotoxic for a microbiome for E
coli
but what about
resistance against these chemotherapies
can bacteria quickly become resistant to
these chemotherapies
we decided to First approach that
question by performing a
loss of function screen genetic screen
what we decided to do was to map the
drug resistor using a genetic screen
approach
in these experiments what we decided to
do is to take a panel of four thousand
strains each strain is mutated in a
single Gene and to test if any of these
loss of functions actually confer
resistance against these two
chemotherapies
that allows us to map the drug
resistance and see if bacteria can
become resistant to these drugs with a
single evolutionary step with a single
Gene in activation
when we did these experiments we found
about a hundred different loss of
function mutations that confer
resistance and what you can see here is
actually clustering of these resistant
strains red means High drug resistance
and on the x-axis you can see which Gene
was actually inactivated of course I
don't want you to focus now on the gene
names I just want to make a very
specific point and that is that the
resistom the profiles or the different
genetic mutations that confer resistance
seem to Cluster not by drug type but by
media type
so we saw a very clear as this storm for
rich media a very clear resistance for
poor media and a few mutations that
confer resistance both in poor and in
rich media
what's the underlying biology so let's
start off with a Target pathway
in the upper right corner you can see
the diagram I showed you before the drug
toxicity I just remind you that these
drugs are transported into the cells and
then are phosphorylated by the Salvage
pathway and what we saw actually made a
lot of sense and that is that every
mutation in the drug Salvage pathway
seems to confer
resistance against these drugs while
mutations in the the novosynthesis arm
of this pathway of this network confers
drug resistance
but the remarkable thing was that the
target mutations or the mutations were
not specifically to the nucleotide
synthesis pathway so we definitely found
loss of functional mutations that confer
resistance in that pathway but we
actually found many many more mutations
in other pathways
looking into the biology we rationalize
that a lot of these mutations either in
central carbon metabolism or in
secondary metabolic metabolic pathways
confer resistance by influencing the
flux for the pentose pathway
the pentose pathway
produces intermediates or precursor for
the Nova nucleotide synthesis
so we reasoned is that you can confer
resistance to these two drugs either by
increasing
input or flux into the pentose pathway
By changes in central carbon metabolism
or you can reduce the demand for some of
the intermediate of the intermediate
metabolites of the pentose pathway Again
by mutations in other Pathways like the
pathway for aromatic amino acids
so again we now know that bacteria can
become resistant very very quickly by
single Gene inactivation and that could
transpire for multiple different
mutations in multiple Pathways not just
in the Target pathway
the question that of course arises is
what will transpire under natural
selection and what will actually be the
host implication
if bacteria do become resistant using
one of these mechanisms will that
resistant have any impact on a treated
host in our case on the worm
I think a good analogy to use
is the famous sentence all roads lead to
Rome in our case yes all adaptations
will likely lead to increased drug
resistance the real question is which
road will bacteria actually use to get
to the resistance right and will that
road implicate or have any implications
for host drug resistance of course our
genetic screen cannot answer that
question
to do that
we can actually use lab Evolution
experiments where we gradually evolve
resistance against these drugs under
drug selection
that could help us understand whether
evolutionary adaptation is random each
time taking a different path towards
resistance or do we see some convergence
to specific mechanisms
it could also help us understand where
there are some forces that channel
channel evolutionary adaptations towards
some solutions and not others and we can
see whether we see mutations
transpiring that are part of our loss of
function genetic screens or do we see
completely new adaptation projectors
so we did these lab Evolution
experiments we certainly transferred our
bacteria in vitro for about two weeks in
inhibitory drug concentration media
containing a inhibitory drug
concentrations and then we essay the
revolve strings we tested if they
evolved to become resistant we tested
the host implications whether the Impact
Drug toxicity in the host and we also
used whole genome sequencing to map the
underlying mutations and we did that in
both drugs both in 5fu and fudr we also
repeated that both in nutrient poor and
nutrient-rich media and we did that with
multiple replicants to see if we see the
same again adaptations arising again and
again and again in independently evolved
replicates in the end we isolated pure
clones a single colony of the resistance
strain to test what are the underlying
mutations
in all cases we saw very high or very
dramatic increase in drug resistance
that happened for both drugs in poor
media and in rich media and we also saw
that in some cases the increase in
resistance was dramatic almost 104
within a very short period of time again
pointing or suggesting that under the
right selection bacteria can evolve and
become chemotherapy resistant resistant
very very quickly but the key question
or the interesting question for us is
whether these resistance at the
bacterial level will have any
impact or any influence
on the toxicity of these drugs in a
treated host feeding on the same
bacteria
to answer that question we use the core
culture essay where we co-culture the
worms our bacteria either the ancestor
strain or the evolved strain and Drug
different concentrations
we call culture the bacteria and the
worms and the drones and after 60 hours
we watch these worms under the
microscope and we scored our development
if there's no impact there's no toxicity
for these drugs we expect to see full
development as you can see here in the
black frame we see full development
after 60 to 72 hours
but if drug becomes toxic we will expect
to start to see delayed
development of the worms or in some
cases complete developmental arrest and
we won't see any worms just the eggs
so that's a basic essay it's not an
essay we developed it's essay that was
uh that was used quite frequently in the
past in other papers
so how do our results look like so what
you can see here is just the ancestor
strain the ancestral bacterial strain
being used as diet for worms and you can
see that at least in the context of fudr
one of our drugs even a very small drug
concentrations
impact the worm host
or the drug is still very toxic for the
worms
and even with very low drug
concentrations we see delayed and later
complete developmental arrest so this
drug is very toxic when our worms are
feeding on the ancestor host
when we fed our worms on one of our
evolved strains we actually saw
very reduced drug toxicity so again the
same worms the worms have never seen the
drugs they're just feeding on different
bacteria and in this case the bacterial
resistance actually converts some
resistance to the worms feeding on these
bacteria so you can see here there are
many more black frames meaning we see
proper worm development at higher drug
concentrations than we saw for the same
worms feeding on the ancestor a strain
and of course you can see we can call
this reduced drug efficacy
we can look at other strains and again
we have many evolved strains and we can
score them for either reduced efficacy
or unchanged drug efficacy but of course
we don't want to stare at hundreds of
different images of worms we can
summarize this in this bar graph
what we see in this graph is a summary
of the impact our evolved strains have
on worm development
on the x-axis you can see all the diets
we used either the ancestor strain on
the leftmost bar and the Evolve strains
on the rest of the bars and the y-axis
actually scores the worm development the
host development a different drug
concentrations in this case we're
looking at five a few
and I think what you can see very nicely
is that the host impact can be grouped
into two groups
there are some bacterial diets that go
on and affecting the host drug
resistance or drug toxicity
and there are a few of our evil strains
that have a very very clear impact
and reduce the drug toxicity in the host
or increase the drug resistance in the
host these are the rightmost bars in our
graph
the remarkable thing we saw was that
these actually grow very very nicely
with the evolutionary whole sorry The
evolutionary history of the evolved
strengths
again in all cases bacteria evolved to
became drug resistant to become drug
resistant
but only bacteria that evolved in poor
nutrient media evolved to become
resistant but also confer that resistant
to the worm host
bacteria that evolved in rich media
became drug resistant themselves but
that mechanism of resistance resistance
had no impact on the worm host
a similar picture emerges with bacteria
evolving resistance against fudr only
bacteria that evolved in poor need media
conditions evolved to become resistant
but also had an impact when they were
used as diet for the worm host
well bacteria that evolved on rich media
conditions became resistant to the drug
but the resistant mechanism had no
impact on worm drug toxicity
going back to the analogy of all roads
lead to Rome yes in all cases we saw
increased resistance but
it seems that evolutionary adaptation is
not completely random it's convergent
all strains that evolved independently
on rich media conditions had the same
impact on the wormholes they had no
impact on the wormhogs
all strains that evolved on poor media
conditions reduce drug toxicity in the
worm host
what are the forces that channel
Evolution they seem to be the nutrient
availability during The evolutionary
process during the evolution period
and what is the underlying mechanism of
action is it no adaptation or one of
these loss of function mutations we
already saw in our genetic screen we
can't answer right now but we can
definitely
sequence the Genome of the evolved
strains and try to poke and get an
answer for that question
what you can see here is the results of
the whole Gene of sequencing of these
evolved bacteria the concentric circles
actually show the chromosomes of four
independent lines that evolved in
different media conditions in the two
drugs and the points you see in these
concentric circles indicate that we
annotated a mutation either a loss of
function or potentially a gene modifying
mutation of course it's very hard to
stare at these let's summarize this in a
table so what you can see here is a
summary table of which genes are hit
again and again and again in these
Evolution experiments that's on the
x-axis of this table
and on the y-axis you can see the
evolutionary history during The
evolutionary period
you can see that there are some genes
that are hit again and again and again
genes that are shown in bold are genes
in the Target pathway so we can
definitely see some mutations in the
Target pathway for a nucleotide
synthesis but we can also see mutations
in other pathways
another interesting thing to observe is
that mutation seems to be clustered by
the media type during the evolution
experiment and not by the drug
so we can find media a poor media
specific mutations in Upp and pyre while
enrich media conditions we see other
mutations altogether in femi and pyrh
we also saw a few cases where we saw
drug-specific mutations I won't go into
this but again mutations are just the
tip of the icebergs these are mutations
in central genes for nucleotide
synthesis and they likely have the wider
impact on the flux and the expression of
other genes right the mutations probably
have a much wider impact on Gene
regulation and genome-wide gene
expression do I say that we actually
used rna-seq of the Evolve strain and
compare the gene expression we see in
the evolved strains to the ancestor
stream again we don't have a lot of time
so I won't go into the details but we
definitely saw very very far reaching
implications of these mutations to the
gene regulatory Network and just to
focus on the target pathway we saw that
in the evolved strains we see reduced
expression of the Salvage pathway and
compensatory increased mutations in the
novo synthesis again indicating that
probably we have a balance of the two
conferring resistance less Salvage and
more flux through the novo synthesis and
of nucleotides
so let's wrap it all into a single model
we start off with a system where
bacterial metabolism actually leads to
accumulation of a toxic intermediate for
these chemotherapies and that toxic
intermediate is highly toxic for the
worm host
the naive State before any adaptation
both bacteria and the warts are very
very sensitive to these two drugs to
five of you in a few Dr
if bacteria evolve in rich media
conditions they themselves become
resistant and they do that by reducing
the flux through the the novo sorry the
Salvage pathway and by compensating by
increased Flux Of The the
nervousynthesis pathway but they still
accumulate a lot of that toxic
intermediate
therefore they're still very the drugs
are still very toxic to the worm host on
the other hand if the same bacteria
evolve in pool media conditions
they become resistant but they do that
by completely inactivating the sandwich
pathway they have no reason to keep that
pathway active because there aren't any
extracellular metabolites that they need
to salvage so they completely inactivate
the Salvage pathway and again they
highly activate or they increase the
Flux Of The de novosynthesis pathway but
that adaptation mechanism confers
resistance both to them and also to the
worm host feeding on these bacteria
so going back to the our first triangle
of interaction yes in this case we know
that bacteria can evolve very quickly to
become chemotherapy resistant and that
bacterial adaptation will frequently
influence the host treatment
think about that concept for a sec
we typically think of evolved resistant
against chemotherapies coming from
genetic changes to the cancer cells
themselves
but what we're showing here is that the
same resistant could transpire By
changes in the microbiome either the
natural side or in the tumor microbiome
and not for genetic changes in the
cancer cells themselves
now of course this work is on a very
simplified model system the worm model
system but then my lab is trying to use
other model systems as infected
tumoroids or infected tumors in mice to
study that adaptation process and we're
even looking at the clinical isolates
that we get from resected tumors from
patients of course each one of these
model systems offers pros and cons when
it comes to tractability and clinical
relevance
the last slide I want to show you is how
these experiments actually transpire in
the mouse model system what you can see
on the left hand side are luminescent
bacteria that we engineered to be
luminescent if we inject them to the
blood system systemically of mice
bearing subcontaneous tumor they very
quickly home and stay specifically
within the tumors and they do that for a
long period of time so they do harm the
tumor and they do form their own
microbiome there and then we can resect
these tumors that's what you can see on
the right hand panel it's a resected
tumor that still has this like bacteria
we can isolate these bacteria sequence
them and study them
a wrapper by thanking the people who
were involved in this research and my
two fabulous students Brittany and
circon Peter who was a rotation student
in my lab During the period where we did
this research This research was also a
collaboration with Marion warhouse lab
and her student Ari from the Department
of system biology and of course my
funding sources from the NIH thank you
very much
and that will be it